I think we pissed them off
good night my father was you started out
just like you this is our time and we
are Earth's lost the best
[Music]
now help ease take the world let's go
already three two what
these things ain't that tough there's
something you need to see
well he's pretty big
[Music]
Plan B always a plan B we've got this
Lasserre absorbers
[Music]
I think I could get used to this
[Music]
[Music]
how you doing Nate its Ranger Lambert
yeah the love well this is a military
base you remember how that works
Ranger Pentecost and you must be Amara
Nnamani yes sir
Ranger sir well let's get you squared
away oh and try not to steal anything
while you're here
did that haircut just call you Pentecost
as in badass stacker Pentecost pilot of
coyote tango hero of basically the whole
world listening yeah really cool name
I'm gonna go kill off you got some just
gotta stop
oh my god that's true of ember Ajax
pilots of unregistered Jaeger this is
the Pan Pacific Defense Corps power down
and exit your comp are way too easy
that's what they think
stop
you are in violation of code 10 section
14 operation of an unregistered Jaeger
plus we got it
[Music]
I think we pissed them off good
oh hell yeah
[Music]
it looks hot
[Music]
thank you know I'd hug you if I didn't
have a rule about public displays of
attractions fine grab with me let's take
care of the jobs right back Jake your
father always said he wanted you to be a
pilot
he said the law thinks I'm not hero like
he was the kaiju they're gonna come back
I'm not gonna be stuck waiting for
someone else to come save my ass cadets
you better gear up
[Music]
[Music]
this is the way the world has had their
gains why won't someone let them in
someone from out world who is that
definitely not one of ours
this is your chance to make cities right
we're gonna need more violets we haven't
there are pilots we remember as legends
but they didn't start that way
they started out like us this is our
time to make a difference
do you understand
Jakub pilots do you understand one way
to find out that's what I'm talking
about
[Music]
gonna be a long day what do we do we
fight
Oh
I loved the first Pacific Rim in that
classic tale of robots and monsters that
hold weights in that holds power I grew
up watching the old giant monster movies
from Japan the classics like Ultraman
space Giants and of course Godzilla I
just ate it up
everybody has felt that fleet and when
those monsters go through a city
it creates an instant excitement with
the technology we have we have a chance
to make it that much more spectacular
mother decorated Cohen economist Naruto
and science are king Cara Mata and McCoy
and Stein automatically and of course
demo dr. collected coitus ultimately
it's a world conflict and everyone's put
aside their differences and come
together many you enter this program you
join a family we stand together that's
what makes us strong
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
I'll help me save the world Pacific Rim
uprising gives an answer back to those
monsters that we've grown up watching if
they were to attack us what would we
have we have the Eggers the fight
sequences of different than in any other
movie I've ever done you're plugged in
and you're along for the ride
[Music]
amara don't scrapper she's committed her
whole life to this Jaeger there's things
about the kaiju that we've never seen
before
it's just epic
I can't announce that this is the most
action I've ever done
like get a ticket to the best books in
my seven
[Music]
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters that destroyed our cities
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough but
the war we thought we finished is just
beginning and the only thing standing in
front of the apocalypse
is us but it doesn't matter where you
came from people leave for you and who
didn't
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
drop from my ball
Lara
they evolve and they could wipe out all
life
[Music]
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty bad
[Music]
by everything you got
[Music]
[Music]